hi my name is Fred with Android
developer relations team we're going to
talk about improving Android studio
performance on memory constrained
computers Android studio comes with many
features developers expect from a modern
IDE for example link checks help
identify errors as you're typing source
code in the editor these developer
productivity features mean increased
resource requirements on the host
operating system practically developers
working on complex multi module
production projects usually have a
gigabytes of RAM or more however if
you're working on a simple project on a
memory constrained computer with say 4
gigabytes of RAM or less we're gonna go
through several things you could do to
make the development experience a bit
smoother there isn't a definite answer
on the minimum specs needed to run
Android studio because there are so many
factors an obvious first step is close
any unnecessary applications on the
operating system sorry for those users
that keep 20 web browser tabs opened for
those that have anti-virus software
running on the computer note that build
files generated by the IDE may trigger
real time virus scanning this competes
for system resources if possible go to
your virus scanner configuration and
exclude project build output directories
Android studio has a default maximum
Java heap size of 1.2 gigabytes if your
computer has low Ram you should
correspondingly reduce the default heap
size to something like 512 megabytes you
can set the desired values using the X
MX key in the studio dot VM option
configuration file by following these
instructions note that reducing this
value means shrinking the amount of
resources for features within Android
studio for example performance of the
layout editor may be affected now let's
talk about Grado one of the core
components in Android studio update to
the latest versions of Gradle and
android plug-in for Grado to ensure the
latest performance optimizations are
available to your project for example in
3.0 with improved
criminal packaging with a apt to the
snippets here shows specific
configurations for the Android studio
3.0 beta version your specific installer
version may need a different set of
values next I'm going to talk about
several techniques that have to do with
degrading support and leaving only the
bare minimum running note that some of
these techniques could provide
performance gain at the expense of code
quality so you really should use with
caution
Android studio provides a power safe
mode when turned on it will disable a
number of background operations that
perform lynch X code completions and so
on there'll be a point in time when you
want to execute any disabled operations
manually take Lynch X for example you
can manually run them through the
command line as shown here some of you
may be using the Android emulator on
average it consumes two gigabytes of RAM
if possible use an actual Android device
this will help reduce resource load on
your computer alternatively if you must
use an emulator consider reducing
emulated RAM which will also decrease
virtual memory consumption on your
computer this configuration can be found
under Advanced Settings in virtual
device configuration Gradle offline mode
is a feature for bandwidth-limited users
to disable downloading of built
dependencies as a side-effect this could
help improve performance on low RAM
machines since this also reduces the
amount of background processing Android
studio offers an optimization to compile
multiple modules in parallel on low Ram
machines this feature will likely have a
negative impact on performance you can
disable it in the compiler settings
dialog I hope this video gives you some
ideas on how to fine-tune Android studio
and your low RAM environments to make
the development experience smoother to
learn more check out the Android
developer site thanks for watching
[Music]